je m'appelle yannick j'ai 29 ans et je
suis célibataire depuis deux ans et demi
à peu près aujourd'hui j'aimerais fonder
une famille avoir des enfants
leschi rire avec ma femme à la sexualité
pour moi c'est quelque chose d'important
tout le temps c
mais si je devais la décrire un médecin
dimanche veut
prise est allumé
j'aimerais que ma femme soit
entreprenante de temps en temps lafleur
aux yeux
yannick merci d'être là alors yannick
franchement dans l'émission d'hier
c'est énorme ce qui s'est passé tu vas
nous dirons aussi en voilà où tu en es
parce que c'est important pour nous
juste avant j'aurais qu'on voit les
vélos d'épisodes ce qui nous a fait rire
nous c'est ta première mine nos ce temps
faites tout avait été mis en place pour
créer une petite ambiance romantique
très sympa mais toi tu as qu'une seule
envie c'est à fricoter bon je sentais
que je la tire et moi aussi elle me
plaît j'ai envie d'aller plus loin avec
elle
moi j'ai envie de dormir avec elle
précis et souhaite que j'avais dormi
dans le canapé j'aimerais pas m'excuser
il indique station jus pressé et puis je
pense qu elle aussi ma mission est la
seule à chanter rex je pense que ce soir
c'est le grand bain
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
d'avoir participé à cette aventure à
cette émission très heureux vraiment
très heureux et content alors ta mère au
départ elle n'était pas très très
contente de cette émission c'était tout
à fait normal
voilà et mme après la kiffer après
lorsqu'on rend beau bon et qu'on passe
très bien fait non bref j'ai vu qu'à moi
c'est un personnage exceptionnel
regarder au début affectif par boualem
pas trop comment avec qui je participe à
l'édition meilleure voiture et c'est
quoi le cancer et avait pas assez
intéressé en bourse
donc du coup ce que tu penses
peut-être que je me marie moment
non je voulais lui pour toi toute la
nuit
monthey nuit
toi
ni yannick mois voilà je te lis j'adore
l'émission j'ai adoré ça m'a manqué un
flic un franc-parler exceptionnels est
en fait toi tu avais aussi un problème
c'est que il ya un extrait ton mariage
que les téléspectateurs ont beaucoup
commenté c'est lorsque ta nouvelle belle
mais hier la maman mais nina tu avais
lancé un joli compliment en pleine
cérémonie
et là c'est vrai que son lit mais
qu'est-ce qui se passe apparemment elles
sont toutes sur yannick qu'est ce que
c'est que ce buzz
voyez vous si j'étais pas mariée je
pense que j'aurais pu prendre la place
de ma fille je sais pas sur un texte
d'accord
vous allez faire un très joli couple
c'est reparti
et vite
[Applaudissements]
moi je kiffe en tout cas lorsque la
maman me dit ça qui fait en gros ça veut
dire que la mère ma belle mère me vanina
bien sûr oui mais moi aussi j'ai à tour
et a cassé mon là elle est très mamère
elle a répondu à la pas trop à accepter
parce qu'elle n'a pas compris le petit
jeu en fait ouais mon nom mais alors
dans l'épisode d'hier on a pu suivre ton
premier dîner chez sa belle famille sauf
que médina est assez sèche avec sam
avant l on quitte les deux un caractère
très très fort et du coup pendant le
dîner n'était pas hyper bien j'ai senti
fait normal aussi
je m'explique pourquoi on fait comme
vous avez pu voir 2001 ne seront pas
très bien avec sa mère mais ça c'est des
choses qu'on n'a pas besoin on n'a pas
besoin forcément de rentrer dans
l'intimité
ça reste entre eux mais entre mère et
fille donc voila moi à ce moment là le
seul truc que j'ai envie c'est que ça
passe moi j'ai pas à la base
effectivement il ne veut pas avoir cette
embrouille devant moi parce que moi je
suis je suis innocent entre guillemets
mais je peux pas interposé dans tout ça
et leur dire directement arrêter de
parler de tout ça mais moi le seul truc
que je veux savoir c'est pourquoi est-ce
qu'elle agit comme ça en fait à ce
moment là donc je vais pas lui poser la
question directement pour don pour parce
que tu es comme ça mais il n'a donc on
en a parlé après le repas elle m'a
expliqué de pourquoi son comportement il
était ainsi et puis à partir du moment à
partir de ce moment là je peux juger
tout tu fais des sentiments pour médina
ou pas des sentiments non non quand même
pas en fait personne ne sait
ça fait à peine quelques jours on se
connaît à peine enfin en tout cas la
mairie on pourra être un oui c'est ma
femme et c'est pas parce que c'est ma
femme kamerhe pour troubler vraiment
vous étiez trop là je suis je suis perdu
je suis je tombe amoureux effectivement
mais après faut que ça perdure tout çà
et là la vraie j'apprends la kone a
commencé avec médina il a pu l'alliance
bah écoutez ce n'est qu'on voit dans la
rue à voir demain
donc c'est fait exprès comment ça va ça
va très bien je suis toujours heureux
pour améliorer un message bizarre sur
les réseaux sociaux quand même lordinot
oui vous avez relayer un message dati
coup vous dites que tout peut se briser
en amour
qu'on peut être déçu tout ça c'est le
jeu j'adore les petits phrases de les
phrases comme ça là des rapports et
j'adore les ripostes vous allez ont
vaincu en riposte beaucoup et en fait
dès que ça me touche moi même les
chansons pareilles
les chansons donc ça me plaît je mets un
petit passage accorde au stade rien à
voir avec votre histoire non ça n'a rien
à voir
est-ce que yannick vous êtes franchement
comment on se demande tous commencé
c'est que t'as pas trouvé la femme de ta
vie avant mais à écouter comment
expliquer ça je pensais l'avoir trouvé
ma faim ont fait parce que j'ai eu des
femmes agile et des femmes avant ça ça
c'est fini
j'ai eu plusieurs conquêtes
effectivement je me suis amusé à partir
du moment où j'ai voulu me poser je n'ai
repris quelques unes et puis celle que
j'ai voulu avoir ne voulais pas
forcément deux mois n'était pas
forcément intéressés et après magie
cette opportunité de participer à cette
expérience là et j'ai sans hésiter j'ai
dit oui alors que ta belle mère et à
côté de taulé
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je regrette pas du tout d'avoir fait
cette aventure non pas du tout mais faut
vraiment prendre beaucoup de recul
ouais parce que c'est normal en critique
mais moi je vous reçois des messages bât
a blessé je réponds même pas
eelv après je peux pas se voir parmi
tous les messages sûr mais on a la télé
on critique tous même mois au final j'ai
regardé cette émission j'ai déjà
critiqué a aujourd'hui je suis dedans
enfin cette émission car il a d'autres
aussi ariane fake si yannick c'est à
dire vous savez rien n'est préparé
vraiment tout et on enfin on est
vraiment libres libres de faire ce qu'on
veut effectivement ils nous proposent
des activités parce que voilà c'est
c'est comme vous le savez tout est enfin
tout est frais payés par la production
on a rangé à part mon rien mais sinon on
est libre il n'y a pas de tien tu fais
si tu fais ça
voilà non non je peux dire non et je
peux dire non mais sauf que moi je peux
tout tranquille posez donc mais il a
vous voyez bien des fois l écart et ça
c'est très bien à la pâte double face à
elle elle agit comme ça avec sa mère
d'autres personnes n'auraient pas agi
comme ça tu penses que tu penses que ça
va aller loin avec mélina bas ça je peux
pas vous dire on verra ça ne la sent pas
d'histoire surtout qu'à pourtant là je
resterai en contact avec eux là par sms
bravo à eux parce que lundi serait se
régale je fais je fais ça après je
regarde pays bas après je regarde tout
chopin qui voit la chose à cacher
quelque chose dira pas ce qu'elle dit
n'est c'est chaud entre effectivement la
belle mère et sa fille vous ça va très
bien que médina et d'un coup une voix
off qui nous explique que c'est chaud
entre vous que vous l'appelez et voit
presque plus encore en fait il ya eu
plusieurs moments il ya s'était pas
chaud de ouf
effectivement ce passage là qu'il passe
à la télé c'était chaud mais on a rigolé
on peut pas tout montrer vous savez on
est filmé h/24 et toute personne qui
passe à la télé je pense est déçu et
déçu par moments et en fait on voit que
le côté négatif on voit pas le côté
positif mais en finale il ya tellement
de choses qui sont filmés le côté
positif on va pas dire oh [ __ ] je
kiffe ce moment là on va retenir que le
négatif or depuis je n'aime pas ce
moment là donc il y des moments positifs
et immense qu'il passe à la télé
aujourd'hui c'est pas bien mais au final
dans le fond retard
si demain je vais chez vous
aura des paroles qui seront passés chez
rocher voilà donc le fait que ça passe à
la télé voilà ça fait tout un taureau
yannick toujours amoureux enfin je vais
pas répondre à ça quand même
et bien tout allait bien dans ma vie oui
je suis très bien d'accord pour ce poste
est bien trop seul à bien dans du cac et
bravo pour ton tee shirt on embrasse
booba voilà qui va nous regarder sur
tellement replay